welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid I posted my centripetal force
video over a year ago and in that time
I've gotten many compliments it's nice
to hear these videos help people but
there are also comments of confusion
resistance and of course a few angry
trolls confused and skeptical is okay
but being a jerk isn't so troll names
get rejected anyway I thought I'd
address the confusion and skepticism
with a slightly simpler situation than a
merry-go-round and we all know what that
means you're putting me to work
yep then wait what do I do anyway
find a bucket and fill it with water
where do we find a bucket oh you're
killing me smalls try the janitor's
closet
while he's busy with that here's the
plan I'm going to have him swing the
bucket over his head and if he swings it
fast enough the water should stay inside
the bucket ready yeah all right let's do
this
you
see it stayed inside but here's the real
question
the water has a weight downward and to
push from the bottom of the bucket also
downward so why the heck does it stay in
the bucket the usual explanation
involves a centrifugal or Center fleeing
force you know the thing I always say
doesn't really exist if you're a long
time crazy you know I say this a lot if
you're new to the science Asylum be
prepared to have your mind blown or your
foundation shaken okay so here's the
gist of the usual explanation there's a
third force upward that balance is the
other two and holds the water in the
bucket but this explanation is terrible
because reasons centrifugal force isn't
a real force real forces exist from all
points of view like this weight or this
push those two together are what we call
a centripetal or center seeking force
that upward force only exists from the
buckets point of view our point of view
is not the same as the buckets point of
view you want to see how crazy this
looks from the buckets point of view
why would anyone even want to explain it
that way from our point of view invoking
a centrifugal force is completely
unnecessary
so then why doesn't the water fall down
that's the thing it is falling but so is
the bucket let's look back at that video
in slow motion after he pulls the bucket
up in the first half of the swing the
bucket begins to fall
it just doesn't fall straight down it
falls this way since the water was
already moving with the bucket it keeps
doing that if a container and its
contents are falling together then
there's no reason for them to come apart
which is true even if they fall straight
down
see so what happens if I stop the bucket
from falling I don't know maybe you
should try and find out
so what kinds of things if you swung
over your head buckets of water flails
bowling balls people let us know in the
comments and until next time remember
it's okay to be a little crazy I hate
you